joining me now nigel farage former
brexit party leader
nigel uh first i have to say the queen
absolutely loved donald trump we know
that and second
you know biden may be more popular with
macron merkel and johnson but that's
just because he's
giving them whatever they want in the
united states is once again just footing
the bill for everybody else
yeah well that's certainly true of nato
even more than the g7 summit because
after that and before the putin meeting
he went to nato
to the headquarters in brussels and
donald trump quite rightly called out
nato
because it's been around for 70 years
but the rules of the club are very clear
everybody must pay two percent of gdp
into defense and of course the germans
and the french
are paying about half of that trump did
actually by causing a scene
when he went to nato he did manage to
get some increased contributions
biden turned up and said isn't
everything wonderful so
american taxpayers watching this you
will go on
subsidizing europe's defense without
them paying their fair share so that i
thought
was humiliating but you've talked
tonight a lot
about the media coverage of biden's trip
let me say this
u.s presidents visiting the uk is
normally a
very big deal you know it's something
that innovates people that gets talked
about
biden's visit to the uk i don't think
most people
even knew that he was here because he
said nothing of substance whatsoever
all that he did was agree with the
merkel macro
and sadly to a large extent boris
johnson agenda
that their global warmists they're
welfarists
they're globalists and he literally made
no
impression upon this country at all i've
never seen that before
uh that's stunning and british
journalist katy kay
uh she wants everyone to believe that
biden's strategy of giving the eu
everything
it wants is basically just a good thing
the european union is critical to
america on a lot of fronts at the moment
right particularly in a way because
britain is no longer in it but it's the
european union that's going to be
dealing with china it's the european
union that's going to be dealing with
russia it's the european union that's
going to be dealing with climate change
a hugely important partner for the
united states at the moment
and biden gets that wait a second nigel
the eu is going to take on china are we
is she
kidding me my god
i mean this is ridiculous and i mean
actually but
biden actually looks tough on china
compared to merkel
and macron and all these european
leaders who have completely sold out to
the chinese communist party
you know boris johnson was saying that
we don't want to have a cold war with
china
merkel was saying that china are our
partners a macron
saying much the same thing i i you know
kenny k
and the bbc are part of the problem
and not the solution the fact is even
the tax proposal for a minimum corporate
tax across the western world
even that is an eu proposal that biden
is going along with
and not the other way around so you know
we've got an american president
who frankly i thought about poetry in
his prose
as we heard earlier he can barely string
a sentence together
he's an embarrassment to the usa he's
walked over
by the french and by the germans and i
would say this trip achieved nothing
yeah total doormat and prime minister uh
johnson
he delayed now you're reopening nigel
which i saw
over supposedly fears over the delta
covet variant
but as we see covet cases are
now show that early signs of slowing as
all the outbreaks are now leveling off
in these variant hot spots
uh nigel very quickly your response and
warning to americans
on this issue so we've got the indian
delta variant
cases have been rising rapidly but those
cases have been amongst the younger
population
most of whom show almost no symptoms
whatsoever
amongst the over 50s the vast majority
of who have been double vaccinated
hardly anybody
is going to hospital we should be
learning to live with cobid and yet
government and mad scientists have now
got this incredible degree of power
over our lives they don't want to give
it back and i tell you what
you know when i went to florida a few
weeks ago i saw
how we should manage it we're going down
the wrong road please don't follow
nigel thank you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else